من اجل اشاره واضحه للانضمام الى النيتو
واشياء اخرى يصل ويجول في اكثر من مدينه
وعاصمه اوروبيه في ايام قليله اسطنبول هي
اخر محطه في جوله الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
يريد من نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
امورا وعليه ايضا الانصات لمقترحات
التركيه التي تلعب دور الوسيط في الحرب
الطاحنه هو ضيف في الدوله الراعيه لاتفاق
الحبوب عشيه مرور 500 يوم على الحرب لا
شيء متروك للصدفه اكدت ان قرا ان
المحادثات بين الرئيسين تركز على اتفاق
الحبوب والاسرى وافقي مفاوضات السلام
لانهاء الصراع المسلح عن كثب تبعت روسيا
هذه الزياره التي لا تفسد الوده بينها
وبين تركيا كما اوضح المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان التسويه السياسيه والدبلوماسيه في
اوكرانيا غير حاليا بسبب عدم رغبه كييف
وواشنطن في ذلك مشيرا الى ان موسكو لم
تغلق الباب امام عمليه التفاوض ولكنها لا
ترى اي افق لها حتى الان عن افق واضح
ومحدد لعضويه
الحلف الثلاثاء المقبل في العاصمه
الليتوانيه بزيارته لبعض الدول الاعضاء
القريبه منه جغرافيا لحشد الدعم وتكرار
رسائله المسموعه من قبل والموجهه
للمترددين في قبول عضويه بلاده
قال ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى اكثر من مجرد
التصريح قبل عشر سنوات بان باب الحلفى
مفتوح امامها وفي سلوفاكيا طالب بموقف
موحد
اعتقد انه لا توجد وحده موقف كافيه بشان
مساله انضمامنا وهذا يشكل تهديدا لقوه
الحلف نتوقع وحده صف الحلف لان قوته في
وحدته
تصريحات الامين العام للنيتو المهادنه لا
تعكس حقيقه الانقسامات فبرلين وواشن لا
تريدان الاستعجال في وضع جدول زمني لدخول
اوكرانيا الحلف لان ذلك يعني الدخول في
حرب مباشره مع روسيا يفضل تفاديها
سيؤكدون مجددا ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا
بالحلف
وسيتحدون بشان طريقه تقريب اوكرانيا من
هدفها لم يوضح الصيغه التي سيتفق عليها او
ربما لم تحدد بعد ولا تحظى بالاجماع من
بلغاريا الى التشيك وسلوفاكي انتهاء
بالتركيا سمعت نفس الجمل من الرئيس
زيلينسكي وهي ضمانات امنيه ومساعدات
عسكريه جديده منها بعيده المدى وجدول زمني
للالتحاق بالنيتو سيرددها ايضا في قمه
فيلينوس هذا الاسبوع فهل من فعل غير
الاجابه الدبلوماسيه المسحوبه بوعود
حسابات السياسه المعقده والبعيده المدى
تجعل من الصعب ان تكون كل طلباته مستجابه
الحرب طالت اكثر من اللازم وثمنها يثقل
كاهل الجميع